what's going on guys so as you guys know
generally what I do on my channel is
talk about movies whether it's a new
release or an older film a film that's
so bad that it's good or whatever when
it comes to movie news I try to talk
about the most important things and
things that most people are interested
in they want to know my opinion about
and for some reason every announcement
that comes out of this Batman vs.
Superman movie is pretty incredible and
most people are like hey Chris what do
you think of that because that's kind of
weird I mean when they were trying to
cast Batman they were kind of dangling
Josh Brolin in front of us like Josh
Brolin it would be pretty cool and we
were like yeah that'd be pretty awesome
and they cast Ben Affleck and the
majority the internet was like huh
I am hopeful about that pic as you guys
know they did the same thing with Wonder
Woman they were talking about some
actresses and you're like okay that
could be possible and then they
announced that gal gadot was gonna play
Wonder Woman and the majority Internet
was like huh
that pick however I'm a little more
skeptical about then they pushed the
movie back to 2016 and that was very
depressing for a lot of people but if
they're making a better movie that's
good now they've recently announced who
Lex Luthor is going to be as well as
Alfred for a while they were talking
about for Lex Luthor maybe Joaquin
Phoenix or even Bryan Cranston and a lot
of people were very excited about
Heisenberg being Lex Luthor this time we
get Eisenberg as n Jesse Eisenberg I'll
bet man excuse me Batman I'm Batman come
here um I sent you a friend request on
facebook and you didn't accept it and
I'm wondering why that is because I sent
it to you and it's important with you
accept my friend request because I've
been to Facebook as well don't get me
wrong here I like Jesse Eisenberg I
thought he was fantastic in the social
network I loved him in Zombieland I've
seen him in movies where I thought he
did a very good job in fact just this
past year with now you see me it was
like the first time he's ever not played
a shy nervous reserved character but Lex
Luthor the arch-nemesis of Superman I'm
sorry I don't see this happening now yes
I've heard the tired thing that everyone
has been saying that I myself have said
Heath Ledger dude everyone thought he
was gonna suck as the Joker and look
what he didn't he was amazing yes I
agree but before that he was already in
Monster's Ball and Brokeback Mountain he
had given really good performances
already in films with Jesse Eisenberg
I'm really not seeing it
now look I would love to be proven wrong
I would love to be proven wrong I would
love to walk out of that movie and go
wow Jesse Eisenberg is the only Lex
Luthor I'm ever gonna think about again
because let's face it has Lex Luthor had
the iconic performance that that
character deserves I really don't think
he has I mean Smallville is television
you know and not saying the actor on
Smallville was bad but it's a TV show
Gene Hackman is Gene Hackman he's
awesome but as Lex Luthor it was fine it
was fine for the movies that he was in
but it was more of a comedy role I have
not seen the ultimate portrayal of Lex
Luthor that has not happened yet so this
movie has a chance here this movie has a
chance to do something different
something surprising and you know what
with their casting choices they are
doing things very different and very
surprising well you're like huh they
picked that guy look I love the guy I
think he's a great actor he's very funny
he's very likable I'm not really seeing
him as his character but he could really
surprise me he really could surprise me
and I still have hope these filmmakers
are making good decisions and that we're
gonna see that movie and go I can't see
this another way this is the way it
should be now I've been failing to
mention a very good casting choice
Jeremy Irons as Alfred that's great
that's a great choice I can see that
already Jeremy Irons is such a seasoned
an excellent actor I can really see him
as Alfred and I think that's a very good
choice what I do want to see is I want
to see Batman in his cave like suiting
up getting his armor on he's ready to
fight Superman he's gonna go out he's
gonna kick some ass and Alfred comes up
behind him and goes Master Wayne be
prepared for the fight of the century
between Superman and Batman I'm done you
know I take back what I said earlier I
think the best pictorial of Lex Luthor
I've ever seen was actually from the
Superman animated series that was one
awesome badass Lex Luthor what do you
guys think of these casting choices I
think Jeremy Irons is an inspired choice
is Alfred Jesse Eisenberg I am
incredibly skeptical about even more
skeptical than gal gadot we'll have to
see how that goes
until next time guys let me know what
you thought below and as always thanks
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]